how many times have we heard or said the
phrase It's Complicated often our
circumstances in life feel overwhelming
and it's hard to picture how we can ever
pile more on top of our already hectic
days but when I found minimalism and
began to declutter the excess in my life
I was left with the realization that
because I had so much it was difficult
for me to appreciate and value all that
I did have it took getting rid of over
90 percent of my wardrobe selling and
donating many of our possessions and
many emotional breakdowns as God also
decluttered traumas and fears within my
heart I'm still a work in progress by
the way but something funny happened in
the midst of it all I began to do things
that at one point I never would have
bothered or had the time to do hey I'm
yesi on this channel we talk about
minimalism and slow living and today I'm
going to share with you the 10 ways that
I intentionally complicate my life to
live happier if minimalism and slow
living sounds interesting to you be sure
to like And subscribe so that YouTube
can recommend to you more positive
content like this and also be sure to
check out my opposing video on the 25
tiny ways to simplify your life I'll
link that one in the description box
below the first one on the list is that
I use my non-dominant hand daily I am
right handed and so I forced myself to
write with my left hand flip pancakes
with my left hand brush my teeth with my
left hand and just throughout the day
try to remember to do things with my
left hand and I did it because I really
want to focus on being present and in
the moment in a world that's constantly
busy it's hard to just slow down and
allow yourself to be without thinking of
what you have to do and all the things
that need to get done
it has been three months now and it's
still hard for me and I still catch
myself like I'll be cooking and I'll be
using my right hand and I'll just
remember oh gotta use my left hand but
that little O is a moment where I am now
reminding myself hey Jessie be present
think about what you're actually doing
don't just go through the motions
if you feel like you can use some more
gratitude in your life some more
mindfulness maybe this can be a great
trick for you number two is that I wake
up early and go to sleep early waking up
early especially when I wake up at 4 30
or 5 in the morning is definitely not
something comfortable to do and it's
something that most people wouldn't want
to do but I find that I'm much more
productive this way I get so much more
done throughout the day and then usually
because of the things that I do
throughout the day and just tips that
I've already applied in my life I get
much better rest at night helping me to
be more productive the next day if
you're trying to adopt a morning routine
or a night routine to help you get
better sleep at night but also be more
productive during the day check out my
video how I wake up at 5am that's packed
with tips to really help you get a
better sleep at night so that you can be
your most productive self the next day
number three cold showers I made a
challenge to myself and went for two
months every single day taking cold
showers the first thing that I did every
morning you may be thinking that this
sounds like complete torture but for me
I found that it was actually something
that once I started doing it for a while
it was something that I kind of enjoyed
because it felt so invigorating it
helped me to wake up in the morning I
just felt like I was so much more
clear-minded some of the benefits is
that it can help you become more
disciplined it can help you have better
mental Clarity and it can actually boost
your levels of dopamine but it's
definitely not for everyone I know that
my husband who has back issues loves his
hot showers especially before bed
because it helps him relax so that he
doesn't have pain throughout the night
so it's not for everybody but if you're
interested give it a try see how it goes
number four is to cook things at home
and make things from scratch I admit
when Rudy and I got married I was
definitely not a good cook I would often
burn things overcook them undercook them
just think that because a particular
seasoning was yummy if I poured the
whole bottle in it would be even yummier
but it but over the years as I've had
more practice I've developed my favorite
meals my go-to meals that I now feel
confident in making I've definitely
simplified the way in which I cook my
meals the types of seasonings that I use
and I think that this has helped me
sometimes if we don't really know how to
cook or we don't really enjoy cooking
because I used to hate cooking it was
really helpful for me to just kind of
simplify and stop trying to make all
these wonderful gourmet dishes that had
all these complicated steps and
complicated ingredients when I started
to simplify that it was so much easier
to cook I ate healthier and we didn't
have to spend money on buying things out
as much have a garden and grow your own
herbs just like I admitted that I hated
cooking I never particularly liked
gardening or found really any joy in it
until Rudy introduced me to cooking with
herbs and my mind was blown I thought
this food was the most delicious thing
that I had tasted and I just can't see
myself cooking without herbs anymore
so we have grown our own herbs for years
now and in the summertime we also have a
garden and I don't know if it's just
like a psychological effect because when
you work on your own food when you
finally taste it in your own plate it
just tastes so much better this is
definitely something that kind of
complicates our life and that we have to
take care of the weeds and you know
water them and you know take care of
them on a regular basis but it's
something that I really enjoy and I
really can't see myself not having a
garden and growing our herbs anymore
before we go to the next one let me know
what is one thing that complicates your
life but you're actually happier because
of it put it down in the comments below
hand wash and dry your dishes
immediately I'm not saying that this is
for everybody but I know that when I
lived with my parents they had a
dishwasher and I just felt no point to
it because you still had to kind of
rinse the dishes put it in that machine
get that thing all ready it would take
forever for the machine to wash and then
you still had to put them away and half
the time they were wet to begin with
anyway and also when we moved into this
house I really wanted it to be as open
as possible so having a dish rack was
not something that I wanted to stare me
in the face every day so we have kind of
a house policy that after we eat we have
to immediately put the dishes in the
sink and usually after meals they'll be
washed dried and put away and this way
it kind of stays clean throughout the
day rather than having piles stacked up
for me it maybe takes a couple steps
more but it really doesn't take as much
time as you would think and my home is a
lot cleaner for it this next one has got
to be one of my favorites and it is to
eat your meals outside and or cook
outside even in the winter time Rudy and
I love to take our meals outside it does
take a little bit more time because you
have to take your dishes out and bring
them all back in but the ability to sit
outside in nature to just watch the
birds in the trees
to just slow down and relax and again
allow yourself to just be I love that
feeling and we definitely try to add it
into our routines as much as possible
if you don't want to go all out and
actually have like a full-on meal
outside but then maybe just take your
snacks outside and see how it makes you
feel take the stairs and park far away I
admit I began parking far away when I
started driving a truck if you have a
truck you'll know you just you have to
park far away because they're bigger
they just take up more space so you want
to be as far from Vehicles as possible
in the beginning I thought that this was
a nuisance but once I started doing it
for a while I actually kind of enjoyed
that because it meant that I got more
exercise in throughout the day
especially when running errands and
going to many different places where I
live I don't have the opportunity to
bike or walk or to take a bus but just
making this small change can allow me to
get a little bit more exercise and what
could otherwise be a very sedentary
lifestyle and not only can taking the
stairs over the elevator be a great way
to get your heart rate going but it can
also be a great exercise of gratitude
because how awesome it is that we have
cars to get from point A to point B and
that we have the option of elevator
where some countries don't have these
options available if you can make it
your challenge today to take the stairs
and park far away number nine I have
real houseplants I talked to you guys
about my horrible spending habits so I'm
not going to get into detail on that but
I did used to buy a lot of fake plants
and fake flowers and I thought that
those were better because I didn't have
to pay attention to them but something
happened in me when I started to
declutter and get rid of things I
started to Value taking care of things
because now that I didn't have so much
cluttering my home the things that I did
have were things that I valued I
definitely get a lot of value and Joy
from my plants but they're actually
something very healthy for you because
they help to purify the air NASA
actually recommends you have one plant
for every 100 square feet of space that
you have in your home for Optimum air
quality lastly number 10 is I used the
reusable option whenever possible I have
two separate videos with tons of ideas
for items that you can swap out the
Disposable version for the reusable
option but I'm not gonna lie the
Disposable can sometimes be the easier
option to go for
so take my menstrual cup in pads for
example I could definitely use the
Disposable version just toss it in the
trash and never think about it again but
I would be spending more money to buy
these over and over again I'd be
spending more time to go back and forth
from the store to buy these items they
would be taking up more space within my
home and I would be harming the
environment
so for me I prefer the reusable option
whenever possible and as a bonus for
sticking to the end decreasing our
income dramatically this year I will be
quitting my college career to pursue
other dreams I'm incredibly blessed that
my husband supports me in pursuing my
passions but it will definitely
complicate our lives as we will be
taking away our only stable income
source and our health insurance which in
the U.S I don't even want to talk about
the medical system and it will also mean
that we will further have to slash our
budgets if you want to hear all about
why I quit my job how I planned for it
and how I plan to save and downsize even
more be sure to subscribe for more
videos to come but I hope that what you
gather from all this is that nothing in
life is ever perfect and in the end
working hard at something will be as
meaningful as the value you attach to it
I want to do the things I value and do
them with passion
yes even the little things
today I challenge you with a question
what are those little and big things
that you value
and make the conscious choice to make
them
your priority